네. 어, 차 타고 임장. 오늘은
대치동 편입니다. 어, 일단은 여기
건너편이 행정구역상 대치동이에요.
일단 대치동에서 제일 투자같이 좋은
데가 어디야 하면은 바로 이쪽입니다.
지금 삼성역 근처다 보니까
삼성동이라고 좀 착각할 순 있지만
대치동에 투자를 하고 싶다라고 하면은
가장 먼저 여기 삼성역 근처가 제일
좋기 때문에 어쪽부터 보면은 좋을 것
같습니다. 여기 제가 영동대로를
타는데 최근에 막 이면에도 막 2억
넘게 팔린 사례들도 좀 있고. 그리고
여기 우측 편에는 지금 저기 빗썸
있는 곳 있죠? 뭐 3,억에 매입해
가지고 저렇게 단층 건물로 만들어
가지고 지금 사용하고 있는데 뭐 이쪽
편에 있는 부분도 저는 괜찮다고
봅니다. 어찌 됐든이 현대가 요쪽에
들어오면 관련된 업체들이 요쪽
인근으로 들어올 거고 공은 사역이랑
여기 삼성역까지 광장이 될 거거든요.
여기서 이제 걸어다닐 수 있게 돼요.
그래서 우리 광화문 관장처럼 진짜
강남구 아니면 진짜 서울시 내에서
정말 핫플레이스가 될 거 같아요. 제
생각에 정말 천지 개벽을 할 그런
곳이라고 생각을 하기 때문에 이쪽
편을 우선적으로 좀 보면 좋을 거
같고 그래서 대체적으로 이쪽은 좀
오피스 상권으로 좀 이어져 있어요.
기본적으로 먹자 상권이 좀 형성되어
있고 위쪽까지는 상권이 그렇게 이어져
있지 않습니다. 그래서 위쪽까지는 막
언덕길도 심하고 상권은 그냥 딱 여기
이면에 있는 좀 넓은 도로 있는
정도까지만 이제 상권이 좀 형성되어
있습니다. 그리고 여기랑 저기 선능력
이면도 이제 대치동이거든요. 그래서
그쪽도 상권이 좀 괜찮긴 한데 거기
제외하고는 이제 우리가 다 아는 그런
대치동 학원 쪽이 상권이 제일
좋다라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다.
일단은 요로 넘어갈게요. 진짜이 건물
예전에 나왔을 때 진짜 거의 하루
만에 계약된 거 같아요. 저거 진짜
계약하려고 막 건물집은 집에 막
찾아가고 그랬었는데 깜짝할 사이에
팔렸습니다. 그리고 여기 건너편에요
아파트가 뉴스 많이 나왔던데 그 추가
분당금 뭐 10억 넘게 낸다고 막 해
가지고 기사 나왔었는데요 아파트 근당
설정에서 안 하면 키를 안 준다고
하더라고. 근데 그 사이에 정확한
어떤 이슈가 있었는지 모르겠는데 뭐
공사비도 많이 오르고 뭐 조합원이랑
이슈도 좀 있었던 거 같고 건설사
입장도 저는 이해는 하거든요. 그래서
아마 현대 건설이 지었던 거 같은데
저희 동목 건설업 하고 있지만 저거는
보증을 쓰거든요. 건설사에서. 그래서
진짜 저 현장이 진짜 엎어지면
건설사도 리스크를 굉장히 많이 두고
하는 거여서 많이 남겨 먹는 거
아니냐 했는데 뭐 다 투명하게 대부분
나와 있고 사실 이익률이 그렇게 높지
않습니다. 가보죠. 대치
사거리에서이자 예전해서 이제 이쪽
부분부터는 이제 학원이 많이 밀집되어
있죠. 학원이 또 좋은게 임대료
수준이 그래도 높아요. 오피스보다는
좀 높고 그리고 이제 상부층까지
이렇게 학원이 좀 잘 들어옵니다.
대치동 이렇게 임대를 한다 그러면 또
학원 수요가 꽤 많이 있어 가지고요
수준도 높을 뿐더러 임대도 되게 잘
되는 거 같아요. 근데 저는 요즘에
또 드는 생각은 또 보여 드릴 건데
뭐 임대 위치 좋은 거 좀 잘 맞춰진
거는 막 거의 20만 원. 그거보다
조금 넘는 것도 있긴 하는데 기형적인
거 있잖아요. 로데오에 막 평당
임대료가 100만 원에 맞춰져 있고
연무장길에 막 100만 원에 맞춰져
있고 막 명동급으로 맞춰져 있는 거
막 보면은 대치동 학원 임차인이 너무
좋긴 하지만 그런 데가 더 낫지 않나
뭐 이런 생각도 하게 됩니다.
예전에는 대치동이 저는 되게
좋아하는데 물론 이제 지금도 좋긴
하지만 인대료 수준이 막 그런
지역들이 막 이렇게 엄청 폭등하는 거
보면서 물론 이제 안정적이긴 하지만
봐야 될 것 같습니다. 제가 봤을 때
저는 어찌 됐든 입시나 이런 시장이
제 개인적인 생각입니다, 여러분.
입시나 이런 시장이 줄어들 거
같아요. 이건 어쩔 수 없어요. 근데
이제 여기 대치돈 같은 경우에는
그래도 다른 이런 학원가보다는 그래도
제일 안전할 것 같습니다. 그다음에
이쪽으로 가면은 연예인분 기사 나왔던
거 있죠? 건물이 이제 팔렸습니다.
그 건물이 38억 정도에 매입했다가
110억에 이번에 팔았어요. 건물
신축하고요 건물 뭐 연예인 분이
매각했다고 기사 많이 나갔었는데
저희가 38억이었을 때 중계를
했었습니다. 그리고 여기가 이제
음마파트 사거리입니다. 여기가 제일
어떻게 보면 중심지죠. 뭐 지금
시간대는 그렇지만 저녁 시간대 오면은
여기 도로가 꽉 차 있어요. 진짜
차가 다닐 수 없을 정도예요. 퇴근할
때 이렇게 좀 여기 피해서 가는데
이게 어떻게 보면 대치동에서 제일
좋은 건물이에요. 사이즈로도 봤을
때도. 그래서 요게 이제 1억 초반
정도의 낙찰이 되는데 뭐 1억 이상
떨어졌다 해가지고 여기 망했다 뭐
이런 얘기 하는데 제가 봤을 때이
정도가 시세거든요. 근데 감정 가액이
왜 이렇게 높게 되는지 모르겠네요.
그리고 저게 수익이 되게 잘
나왔어요. 거의 한 3억 중반 정도
나왔던 거 같은데. 그래서 지금
낙찰가액 대비했을 때는 거의 한 4%
후반 거의 5% 가까이 된 거
같습니다. 수익성이 되게 좋고 그리고
연면적 대비했을 때는 평당 임대료가
한 20만 원 정도 되는 거 같아요.
그리고 여기 이제 배우 세대가 되게
많아요. 그래서 뭐 대치동 학원과
투자한다 그러면 아까 음마 아파트
사거리 쪽 그쪽 공매 나왔었던 거
건물 근처나 아니면은 여기 한티역이면
이쪽으로 많이 투자하는 거 같아요.
그래서 저희도 건물 만들면 임대가 잘
돼요. 많고 강남에 이면에 애매한
거막 오피스 임대하는 것보다 뭐
이런게 더 날 수도 있어요. 그리고
여기 대로변은 한 2억 대리는 거
같습니다. 2억 중반, 후반까지도
있는 거 같고. 최근에 매각된 거
중에 여기 코너 건물 있거든요. 거기
위치요. 여기 보세요.이 지금 공실이
하나도 안 붙어 있습니다. 코너에
여기 건물. 이게 270억인가 최근에
팔렸는데 위치가 너무 좋아요. 여기
사람이 모이는 그런 위치입니다. 일단
저기까지는 그래도 계속 상권이 확장돼
가고 있어서 여기 근처에 도로 잘
접한 거는 좀 괜찮은 거 같아요.
너무 벗어나지 말고 비어 있는 곳이
없습니다. 아 이건 주차장도 좋다.
그래서 여기도 보면은 다 꽉차
있습니다. 그리고 저희 건너편이 이제
아파트 배우 세대에 있고 여기 보면은
다 이제 아파트 상권 앞에 있을 만한
인체들 다 있고 딱 봐도 좋잖아요.
그죠? 배우 세대 많아서 여기
건물들은 공실률도 낮고 괜찮은 거
같아요. 지금 당장 뭔가 임대 수익
생각한다라고 하면 여기가 제일 괜찮은
거 같아요. 그래서 오늘 좀 대치동을
돌아봤는데 여러분 어떠셨나요? 어디가
제일 좋으셨어요? 블록마다 이제 좀
느낌이 다르고 뭐 가격이라든지 이런게
조금 다르긴 하지만 좀 정리해서 제가
좀 설명드리면 일단 대치동에서 제일
투자 가치가 좀 높은 데는 당연히
삼성력 근처고 네. 그리고 수익성이나
뭐 이런게 좀 괜찮은 곳은 한티역
근처입니다. 한티역 근처나 음마
아파트 사거리 근처 그니까 저는
괜찮다라고 생각을 하고 그중에서도
저는 한티어 근처 거긴 진짜 임대
수요도 되게 다양하고 그리고 번 외로
이제 선능력이면 이제 내려갈수록 평단
가격이라든지 임대료 수준이라든지
이런게 좀 계속 낮아지고 있습니다.
그래서 여러분들이 만약에 투자한다라고
하면 진짜 그냥 애매한 오피스 상권
사는 거보다 괜찮을 수 있거든요.
그래서이 대치동 쪽도 좀 유심히 보면
좋을 것 같습니다. 그래서 오늘
차타고 임장은 여기까지 하고요. 다음
시간에 또 뵙도록 하고 그리고 지금
댓글 좀 남겨 주세요. 여기를 좀
가면 좋겠다라든지 이런 걸 좀 남겨
주시면 저희가 참고해 가지고 다음
영상 촬영할 때 그쪽 지역에 가서
촬영을 하도록 하겠습니다. 오늘 영상
여기까지 하겠습니다. 감사합니다.
[음악]